مساء الخير
اخبار الدين العام او الخروج اللي بتقدر
بها الحكومات لكن في على محدود جدا من
الناس بيشوف في هذه الديون او القروض اللي
بتقتضي الحكومات فرصه لان ممكن كمان حقه
ثروه ممكن تتحقق
قروض الحكومه الحقيقه يقتضي منا ان احنا
نفهم القصه الاول كل الحكومات في كل دول
العالم بل تقترب صبيحه كله
بتقدر لانه كل دوله عندها مصروفات
وايرادات وفي الغالب طبعا بتكون مصر فاتحه
اللي هي الرواتب او الانفاق على المشروعات
البنيه التحتيه والطرق والكباري والصرف
الصحي والتعليم وغيرها كل الحاجات ذي
بتبقى بتحتاج فلوس اكثر بكثير من ارادتها
سواء من الضرائب او من اي شركات تابعه لها
علشان كده بيكون في عكس العجز دائما بين
المصروفات والايرادات هو الذي يسمى عجز
الموازنه العامه عشان تستعد الوزن العامه
بتلك الى الاقتراب وهي تقترب بين
العمله المحليه تقترب عمله اجنبيه
اذا اقتربت بالعمله ال اذا اقتربت بالعمله
المحليه من السوق الداخلي ب يسمى دين
داخلي اذا اقتربت بالدولار او اليورو
والين من الاسواق الخارجيه يسمى دين خارجي
مجموع الى اثنين عربات يسمى الدين العام
الى لو ارتفع بزياده بيمثل طبعا ال خطوره
على استقرار اقتصاد اي دوله لكن
الدوله لما تقترب مصدر من يخرج هذه الدوله
التي يفرضها هو انت وانا او اي موضع
لاموال في البنوك عاده الناس لما بتروح
البنوك وتضع اموالها وهي غير يعني لا تقصد
انها تقرض الحكومه لكن اللي بيحصل ان
البنك انت تضع اموالك في البنك في شكل حسب
جاري او شهاده او وديعه ايا كان شكل
الديمقراطيه اللي انتهت عمله والبنك من
غير ما يستشيرك هذه الاموال انما لا
يستشير في كيفيه استثمارها بيروح يستثمرها
في عده او بعد الطرق انه يعطي الاموال
ديلي مستثمر المشروع او العميل على سياره
او يشتري منزل الى اخر
لكن سواء قرار المستثمرين او عميل على قرض
استهلاكي الشخصيه ان تكون نسبه مش كبيره
من محافظه البنك النسبه الاكبر
للاستثمار الامن المضمون السك وهو اقراض
الحكومات الغالبيه العظمى من اموال البنك
اللي هي اموال المودعين بالتنحي الى اقرار
الحكومه فالحكومه مثلا بتعرض على البنك
انه انا محتاجه منكم وال على شكل اسد عجز
الموازنه والاموال اللي بدي على نسبه مثلا
خمسطاشر في المائه يكون البنكي عمل حساب
انه الودائع الاخرى واشكال الوداع الاخرى
لدى في البنك هو بيبقى عليها نسبه حوالي
12 13 في المئه يبقى هو اخذ منك الفلوس
اطناشر في المائه وان الفلوس للحكومه
خمسطاشر في المائه نسبه الاثنين ثلاثه في
الميادين هي اللي يحقق منها اربعه
المستثمر لاعاده الناس الغالبيه العظمى من
الناس تقرب الحكومه من غير ما تقصد بالشكل
ده انما في مستثمر محترف او مستثمر في
بيروح عن قصد الى البنك اللي بيدعي معك او
الى شركه اوراق ماليه واستثمارات وسيط
مالي يعني ويطلب منه انه يساعده في
استثمار اموالهم مباشره في ادوات التين او
اوراقه الدين وده لا يتطلب منا غير انك
تروح للبنك بتاعك وتطلب انا عاوز استثمر
في الروسي في اموال الدين بتلك الشروط
والحدود الدنيا
اول وسيط المالي وفى الحاله دى انت البنك
او شركه الاوراق الماليه ديه واصيب بيساعد
كل لدخول والاستثمار في الدين الحكومه بين
الحكومه ب ا عباره عن ان الحكومه تقترض
بشكل دوري مرتين في الشهر مره في الاسبوع
على حسب ظروف كل دوله عن طريقه لقاءات
البنوك تدخلها وعند طلبت الى ان تستثمر
البنكي
العملاء من ضمن الاموال اللي هو استثمرها
وبتاخذ العقل بتاعك لم يتحقق في بعض الناس
المستثمرين المختلفين بيفضلوا انه يستثمر
في اوراق الدين الحكوميه مشكل الودائع
والشهادات المعروفه لازمه السبب الاساسي
رقم واحد في العالم كله ان البنك ممكن
وبالتالي ممكن اموالك طبيعه لكن الفلوس
لما بتخرج الحكومه هي ان نسبه المخاطره
شبه معدومه لان من النادر ان الحكومه تفلس
ممكن لكن نسبه يعني بسيطه جدا
وبالتالي هي بتبقى اموال مضمونه تماما
لكن في بالنسبه للعالم العربي الشرطه
لانه الحكومات في العالم العربي او في دول
اخرى من العالم بتضمن اموال المودعين في
كل البنوك حتى لو افلس البنك اذا تستوي
اوراق الدين الحكومي مع الشهادات والودائع
الموجوده في البلد في اخرى في اوراق الدين
مش موجوده في الادوات الاخرى وهي وتسهيلها
لا يترتب عليه ولا يترتب عليه بالضروره
خساره التشكيله
الحكوميه اذا كانت مخزنه او سندات عن طريق
البنك او استمرار المالي
مدرسه موسى الاوليه لم السوق الاوليه لكن
بعد ما بتشكيلها بتبقى فيه الورقه معاك
ممكن تباعا مره اخرى عن طريق الصور
الثانوي اسوا الثانويه ترجع للبنك وتقول
انها او انك ترجع الوسيط المالي اذا كانت
التداول في سوق المال وهو انت ممكن تكون
مش عارفه التفاصيل لكن هي بتبقى بسيطه جدا
لل وصيتي المالي قبل البنك اللي تتعامل مع
انهم يعملوا الكلام ده كل يوم
اللي انه في الغالب تكون العائد على الدين
الحكومي فيها على الاقل في دولنا يعني اذا
ما كانش مساوي
الوسائل الودائع والاشارات الاخرى ممكن
يبقى اعلى شويه في كل الاحوال داء العائد
الذي يعود على ال الحكومه كانت تبقى حصلت
على الاموال
والبنك
فايده او ربحه على استثمار امن وكذلك ان
تتحقق استثمار اه من وسهلا من اموال في
الاستثمار يعني ب مو م ما فيش فيه نسبه
مخطط
الحكومه تقترض عن طريقه كلمه ادوات الدين
دي كلمه يعني تبدو
ادوات
عباره عن الاوراق التي تصدرها الحكومه
علشان تقول لك
اموال يعني هي عباره عن ايصال امانه اشكال
مختلفه بدي اخذ شكل
او اللي هي بيسموه ودون الخزانه او بتاخذ
شكل اللي هي السادات سواء كان خزانه او
السندات منهم غير في فتره الاستحقاق يعني
الخزانه في كل دول العالم اللي هي التي هي
عباره عن
سبيلا او ايصالات امانه تقدمها الحكومه
الفكره قال لا نسال عاده يكون واحد تسعين
يوم ومضاعفاتها لاقل من سنه واحد وتسعين
يوم يعني المطلوبه في اثنين في الثلاثه في
اربعه بحاجه علشان يكون مدتها حوالي
مائتين اربعه وستين يوم والسنه طبعا
مائتين وخمسه وستين يوم في بتكون اقل من
سنه هذه الحكومه المغربيه او السودانيه او
المصريه تقول انا عاوز ايه عاوز مثلا
ثلاثه مليار اي ان كانت العمله لمده واحد
وتسعين يوم البنوك الحكومه بدعم العطاء
العطاء بتدخل في البنوك المختلفه
وتقدم افضل عرض الحكومه افضل عرضه للحكومه
يعني يعني اقل نسبه تكلف على الحكومه
وشكلت وشكل العائد على ادوات الدين
الحكوميه او اوراق الدين الحكوميه يتعدى
يعني مثلا فيما يتعلق ب اذن الخزانه عاده
الحكومات بتدي على قيمه اسميه اتبعوا
بنسبه اقل اقل مثلا الحكومه المصريه تقول
انا اصدر الخزانه بدايه من خمسه وعشرين
الف ان ومضاعفه وتكتب على الهجوم خمسه
وعشرين يعني يستحق بعد واحد وتسعين يوم ان
تاخذ 25 لكن ان تشترك ان البنك يعرض في
العطاء يقول لك انا يشتري بعشرين بحيث انه
هو لما يشتري بعشرين يجي في نهايه ال واحد
وتسعين يوم ياخذ خمسه وعشرين الف هو
استفاد خمسه والحكومه دفعه في بنك ثاني
ولا يحكومه انا مستعد اخذه في المقابل 21
يقول 22
الحكومه تستقر على ارض
العرض اللي هو في الحالتين اقل سعر خاص
سعر الخصم اللي هو الفرق بين القيمه
الاسميه خمسه وعشرين والرقم اللي هو مستعد
يشتري بي في سوره السندات العاديين
السندات العاديه بنسبه الفائده العاديه
اللي احنا بنعرف ها انه انا في سنه
الحكومه عاوز اقترب لمده سبعه سنوات وانه
في مقابل هذا السندات اخذ فلوسك في نهايه
السبعه سنوات مع نسبه الفائده عشره في
المائه خمسطاشر في المائه ايا كان الناس
عموما السندات هي اشكال مختلفه
وفي النهايه اذا كانت تجري او سندات
بالمناسبه امريكا بدي اسمها مثلا الى علاج
اللي هي اقل من سنه في حاجه اسمها اللي هي
اقل من خمس سنين وفي الفوز اللي بقى
السندات اللي احنا بتتكلم عليها ان هي
لغايه ثلاثين ايا كان ال الفرق هو في
النهايه الفرق ما بين الاسماء المختلفه هي
الفتره بس اللي يستحق بعدها عمليه السداد
على الحكومه وفي كل الاحوال العقد اي ان
نسبه الفائده اللي بيحصل عليها المقرر
للحكومه احنا كنا بنتكلم على السوق
الداخلي السوق الخارجي بقي بردو بنفس ال
اليه الحكومه
للسوق الخارجي لاسباب مختلفه اهمها في
حاله بلدان ان تحصل على قرض بعمله اجنبيه
الدولار او اليورو اول انا وايا كانت
العمله وبالتالي هي ب تستعين ديه وسيط و
ليكن مثلا بين كبير سي جي بي جي بي سي جي
بي مورغان اولا الحكومه تقول وان توكيل
القرن لنا ان انا عاوز مليار دولار وعاوز
المده مثلا خمس سنوات البنت بالعلاقات
المختلفه وخبرات بيطرح الكلام دا في السوق
الدوليه يعني السوق الدوليه يعني يطلع كل
المؤسسات الدوليه المهتمه ان الحكومه
المغربيه السلام عاوزه القرض المده كذا
ودين قدرتها على السلام الى اخره ودي نسبه
الفائده البنوك المهتمه
ايضا بتتقدم طلبا للحصول على اربعه
الملوك لما ب تستثمر هذه الاموال يوم
تستثمر اموال مودعين اما عن طريق عاده يتم
الكلام دعمت راضيه عن طريق سندي
متخصصه
متخصصه في اللي هي تستثمر في ادوات الدين
الحكوميه او متخصص جزء اساسي من اموالها
او من استثماراتها من نشاطها في ادوات
الليل
السنه دي اللي بتشوف لتضع الخريطه قدمها
كلها خريطه العالم وتابع كل يوم شوف
الحكومه المغربيه مستعده تؤدي ان كان من
تفيدنا الحكومه المصريه الاردنيه
الماليزيه ايا كانت الحكومه وال تروح
مباشره الى اعلى نسبه فائده و تشتري دون
الخزانه او السندات ايا كانت فترتها في
مقابل الحصول على النسبه الفائده عرفت انه
الشهر اللي بعده ان فيه عرضه افضل من
تركيا ولا من الارجنتين بتبيع فورا وضوح
للحكومه اللي تعرض عليها يثبت فيها اعلى
النوع ده من الاموال او من الاستثمارات
يسمى
او الاموال الساخره لانها تنتقل سريع من
سوء بحثا عن الربع وعلى شكله بيكون فيها
نسبه مخاطره يعني اذا خرج بكميات كبيره
لسوق اخر بتربيه السوق اللي خرجت منه
بتاثر كثير اوي على قيمه
[موسيقى]
الحكومه المصريه مثلا في الفتره من 2018
2018 الفين
اللي ديسمبر 2018 من ارتباك نتيجه خروج
جزء كبير من هذه الاموال الساخنه لاسواق
قدمت عروضا افضل وده الامر اللي اربك شويه
حسابات الحكومه ثم عادت الامور لما الوضع
بقي العرض اللي موجود في مصر افضل من دول
اخرى اصبح فيه تدفقات من هذه الاموال
الساخره
والداخليه مخاطرها لكن ده مش موضوعنا لكن
في النهايه انا بقول لك ازاي بيعملوا ثروه
من اقراض الحكومه
لكم ان تتخيلوا الحكومه حصلت على الدولار
اللي هي عزاء واليورو ليه هي بتلقي هذا
النوع من الاموال لانه هي عشان تحصل على
الدولار او اليورو بالطرق الطبيعيه هي ما
لازم يكون عندها استثمارات حقيقيه مصنع
المزرعه لازم يكون عندها قدره على التصدير
للخارج لازم يكون عندها قدره على اجتذاب
السياحه يعني المصادر المختلفه الحقيقيه
الموارد الدولاريه او العمله الصعبه لما
تقول الحكومه معاش القدره ان هي تحصل على
هذه الاموال بالطريقه دي بشكل كافي او انه
تكون المساله تستغرق وقت وهي في حاجه ملحه
الى عمله صعبه الان ممكن عشان يسد دين اخر
في الحلقه بيضطر
الاموال الساخنه او
الاستثمار في ازمات الدين وباسم واستثمار
هو عباره عن اقرار هو استثمار بمعنى الله
بيعود بالرحله المقرر لكن لا يعود باي
فائده حقيقيه يعني على الاقتصاد المحلي هو
الذي ادى الى صناعه ولا زراعه ولكن هي
عمليه استفاده من حاجه الحكومات الى
الاقتراض ليس اكثر ولا اقل على سبيل
المثال الحكومه المصريه كانت تقدم حوالي 8
المياه على الدولار الى اقربها بالدوران
بتقدم 8 في المياه
في مقابل نسبه تتراوح من ثلاثه في المائه
في اسوء امريكا والاتحاد الاوروبي
وبالتالي هو
بعض المستثمرين المحترفين كان بيحصل على
نسبه اكبر انه يطلب من البنت اللي بيتعامل
مع ان ان يقولوا حاجه دفعه ماليه اولا
بريتش فاذا كان المستثمر دام مستعده ان
يشتري ادوات دين مصريه ميه الف دولار
فيطلب رافعه البنك كيلو كمان مائه الف
دولار في مقابل ضمانه الاوراق الماليه
يروح يشتري وبعد ان بيشتروا يحصل على
نسبته المستثمر بياخذ العائد على الف
دولار الاولانيه وبياخذ كمان بعد خصم
البنك الى المستحقات على القرد النسبه
المتبقيه
بدل ما كان بحوالي 14 ونصف في المائه مثلا
على بعد خصم الضريبه على الاستثمار فى
ادوات الدين الحكوميه ممكن اليه نفسهم
ثلاثه وعشرين في المائه دون ان يمثل القول
اشكركم والى لقاء اخر
[موسيقى]